this president is is really establishing
a tremendous legacy on the environment
as well as the economy and I don't need
to speak to the economy let me speak to
my issues first of all I have been
engaged since day one on efforts to
reduce carbon pollution most notably in
the car industry if you take a look at
the cause of today you have three times
as many models for sale today as you had
when he took office that are 30 miles
again per gallon or more in terms of
their efficiency that is because of
actions of this administration we are
doubling fuel economy by 2025 we're
doing that as a fuel economy standard
and a carbon pollution standard we have
been looking at reducing toxic emissions
from utilities we actually put forward
something that looks at reducing mercury
and arsenic things that we haven't been
able to move forward on and the result
of that is that it's already past the
compliance period we never threaten
reliability we got some some of those
old inefficient units have gone out that
didn't have modern controls our
communities are healthier we're saving
up to 11,000 lives every year as a
result of that we have renewables when
three times as much as when this when
this President came into office ten
times more solar than we've ever had and
these are becoming competitive
technologies we have also have grown in
the in the building trades in terms of
how you build energy-efficient homes and
buildings we have grown thousands and
thousands of jobs we are building the
economy of the future by building in
your considerations on environment into
those decisions we're looking at water
rules today I am actually moving forward
with a final rule that is going to
settle the question of what waters are
important to protect so we can protect
people's drinking water into the future
and how do we adapt to a changing
climate when you have California with
such significant water shortages what
does that mean how do we change the way
we do business
instead of piping water out we're
looking at green infrastructure moving
in so we have a tremendous rich legacy
that this president is going to leave
and I think climate is is really going
to be the one that's most talked-about
but frankly our legacy needs to be that
we're nimble enough as a government and
as States working with the federal
government to be able to see what the
challenges are today and to position our
solutions in ways that grow our ability
to tackle the problems of the future